around the holidays a lot of people do
Secret Santa
with their family or coworkers but did
you know that Santa himself has quite a
few secrets you wear that that's right
ladies gentleman he does and it's time
once again for Santa's secrets
[Applause]
[Music]
let's Santa Claus everybody
good a CEO set up hey Conan does it
going okay Santa do you have any secrets
you'd like to share with us huh oh sure
I've got a lot of Secrets but you
wouldn't want to hear that please Santa
would love to hear one of your secrets
don't be so coy wouldn't we want to hear
his secrets okay okay just one just one
I only checked my list twice because of
my OCD the medication isn't helping Oh
also if I don't like the cookies you
leave out for me I open your front door
so your dog runs away that's that's
weird Santa but thank you for sharing
they have it Santa's secrets we're gonna
move on code it yeah yes yes senha you
want to hear another secret sure we have
time for one more yeah okay good you
want to know what I do the other 11
months of the year I make mess okay are
you dying no I'm not done - sure once
killed a guy that's how he earns my
respect okay great yeah oh yeah
and this Rudolph's nose glows a little
brighter when passing over urban
neighborhoods he's very racist wow I
didn't know he was racist anyway we
should move on also I sold half the toys
we made this year and use the money to
make a mega donation to the Roy Moore
campaign go Roy
Santa that's enough people don't like
that yeah this year Santa's gonna have a
big steak dinner that he's gonna leave
his own hue log under your tree yeah we
know what you mean yeah here's the hint
the Yule Log comes out of my doorway so
I'm gonna poop under your tree
Gove explain thing
you